le temps d'une vie l'éternité et un jour
le film de Theo Angelopoulos sort demain
palme d'oracan où il avait fait
l'unanimité l'histoire d'un homme au
seuil de sa vie l'histoire d'une
rencontre avec un enfant le temps des
regrets de la nostalgie et de la
réflexion Dominique Poncet Roland
barissel lumière sensualité et gravité
ce plan d'un vieil homme qui Val se
lentement dans les bras d'une jeune
femme résume l'atmosphère à la fois
méditerranéenne et nostalgique de
l'éternité un jour l'histoire d'un poète
écrivain qui à la veille de sa mort va
se souvenir de sa vie et méditer sur
l'amour l'exil et la solitude de
l'artiste un film que Théo Angelopoulos
a mis 3 ans à réaliser tant il lui
tenait à cœur il voit tout on peut pas
tricher avec Théo il voit absolument
tout même le moindre sourire si ça lui
plaît pas il recommence la scène il est
aussi capable de dire non aujourd'hui tu
es fatigué tu vas aller te reposé P soit
une heure il est capable il est capable
il est très très très très très à
l'écoute de ses acteurs il est à
l'écoute de ses acteurs mais il est
aussi soucieux de la beauté de ses
images dans ce film il n'est pas un plan
qui ne magnifie le propos du
cinéaste
aos mais là c'est
je pense que ce film je le fais avec un
peu plus d'émotion personnelle au moment
du tournage et au moment de
l'écriture peut-être parce
que c'était le moment c'était un moment
de moi o
jeès
vulra il est comme
ça avec une aucune intention autre
que de parler de C temps qui passe de
ces choses qu'on
regrette des
c quand il fut projeté à can l'éternité
un jour bouleversa public par sa beauté
et la hauteur de son propos de jours
plus tard on luicnaunanité la palme
[Musique]
d'or